c'est un moment qu'il attendait depuis
près de 50 ans à sa troisième tentative
de se faire élire à la tête du pays
joseph robinette biden est
officiellement assermenté en tant que
46e président des états unis
[Applaudissements]
avant lui kamala harris est entré dans
l'histoire devenant à la fois première
personne de couleur et première femme
vice président cheney
oui c'est vrai une journée qui ne marque
cependant pas le triomphe d'un candidat
selon joe biden mais la victoire d'une
cause la démocratie
un discours inaugural
placée sous le signe de l'unité est
prononcée devant trois anciens
présidents démocrates et républicains
bill clinton george bush et barack obama
mais en l'absence notable de dans notre
chambre il faut se voir en tant que
voisin et non comme adversaire dit joe
biden
car 100 unités il ne peut y avoir de
paix seulement de l'amertume et de la
colère en libye nous sommes furieux des
mots qui prennent une résonance
particulière car prononcer sur les lieux
mêmes où deux semaines plus tôt des
partisans de dand sommes entrés de force
dans le capitole pour tenter de
renverser le résultat de l'élection
dans notre chambre qui a choisi de
quitter washington avant
l'assermentation de son successeur un
dernier vol à bord de l'hélicoptère
marine one puis une petite cérémonie
d'adieu avant d'embarquer à bord d'air
force one un aller simple pour sa
résidence de mara lago en floride une
fin de règne marqué par l' isolement
alors que le vice-président sortant mike
pence et le chef des républicains au
sénat mais du mec en or avaient tous
deux choisi d'apparaître plus tôt aux
côtés de joe biden et avec eux des
vedettes du monde du spectacle
[Musique]
lady gaga pour interpréter l'hymne
national
et puis jennifer lopez extrême
la cérémonie d'aujourd'hui s'est déroulé
selon un protocole quasi immuable à une
différence près et s'est tenue devant
une esplanade est quasi déserte
la population était invitée à suivre
tout cela à la télévision
coved oblige sécurité aussi impossible
d'approcher le capitole protégés par des
clôtures des barbelés et des dizaines de
milliers de soldats et de policiers
lourdement armés
alors c'est à quelques encablures du
congrès qui se sont rassemblés ses
quelques centaines de citoyens
partisans et opposants de joe biden côte
à côte
nicholas turner tenait à être sur place
pour vivre ce moment historique
chardy pandore elle est venue du kent ok
pour l'occasion et elle s'avoue déçu de
ne pas avoir pu s'approcher davantage
après la cérémonie c'est à pied que joe
biden s'est rendu à la maison blanche
comme l'avait fait avant lui barack
obama une image symbole car c'est bien
dans les traces d'obama qu'il entend
gouverner
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
washington